[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Kerr at a remote and ancient
paradise of diverse biomes and ancient
faith and a proud society living as it
end
hundreds of years ago we thank the gods
for giving us life
this video series will introduce you to
the many different regions of current
you'll need key characters setting out
unique animals and other elements that
give each region its own unique flavor
and part one we visit the lowlands this
region of kirat is massive from the
rolling hilltops to the wetland marshes
lies a web of narrow mountain roads
extending across the plains the smaller
villages are where the local culture
lives and breathes look at the banner
pause Oh with the golden path and
they're a great place to start your
exploring in this unpredictable open
world
but beneath the peaceful surface hides a
long history of rebellion and oppression
meet Paul de play the plur reports to
the self-appointed king of karate pagan
min and is responsible for leading men's
royal army they make their fortune
running guns selling tea and cultivating
other illegal crops yeah I did this
whole thing run the plur is a brutal
psychopath who poisons the peaceful
lowlands through fear and torture or
don't half Terrace bad guy not good guy
[Music]
if you're going to survive in the
lowlands there are some things you
should know first
navigation hitch a ride in civilian
vehicles like the top top pilot the
hovercraft to explore the rivers and
marshes or take to the skies and the
buzzer and agile gyrocopter perfect for
getting the upper hand on your enemy
you're also going to need weapons to
fend off the plur the Royal Army and the
bloodthirsty beasts that inhabit this
region of correct
there is plenty to do and much to see
around the lowlands of carafe and this
is just in
and part 2 will take you to one of the
most unpredictable and terrifying places
in correct face your judgement pre-order
now for a free upgrade to the limited
edition includes three extra story
missions and a bonus Impaler harpoon gun
pre-order now Far Cry 4 available
November 18 2014